as I mentioned in my opening this is one
of the the distinct pleasures of my job
in any case apart from working with IRA
and Bill and professors Gordon and
Jackson but we're going to give out the
2015 rising stars of corporate
governance award and this is a seventh
annual award from the center and we had
a really wonderful group of nominees
this year is very challenging for the
selection committee all were
accomplished individuals all had
achieved a great deal in what was a
relatively short amount of time but the
the committee really focused in almost
unanimously and automatically on for
exceptional candidates to honor today
and so all right you can sit down i'm
going to call them up and then we'll
present the awards as they come up the
first is Richard fields where's Richard
Richard is with the tapestry networks
many of you probably know him from his
work in particular on sdx he's a
accomplished career already in legal
background he lectures at Harvard but
what the committee would really step for
the committee was his work with
directors and perhaps most importantly
in his efforts to encourage engagement
between directors and investors so
Richard congratulations i'm going to
give our your award if you'll give me
next I'd like to invite up Miriam owe me
from legal general and investments in
the United Kingdom Miriam is the head of
sustainability there and I'll try to
make a very quick remarks on her what
really stood out for the selection
committee through her leadership
coordinated and led a campaign to
promote the benefits of improving
corporate governance and investor
stewardship in Japan which i believe is
playing out as we speak right and a
funny note I was speaking with Miriam
yesterday and I asked her why did you do
this and she said I got frustrated and
so that gives you a sense she went out
and is making a very real impact now so
join me in congratulating Miriam owe me
and last but not least certainly is
nermeen Shehata who is recognizing a
joint award with her colleague ahmed
abdul majeed ahmed could not be here so
they're mean is here to receive the
recognition on both of their parts
nermeen is a visiting assistant
professor in the Department of
accounting at the American University in
Cairo and is recognized for all of our
contributions on the study of corporate
governance particularly in the middle
eastern region but most in particular
for her work that she and her colleague
did in launching the corporate
governance club at the university the
first student based corporate corporate
governance club in Egypt which is now up
and running and expanding as I
understand it so with that I'd like to
ask everyone to congratulate
congratulate her meme
now realizing that where we're standing
between lunch I did want to give each
each of them Richard marioman or mean a
moment to say a brief word hello thank
you and then and then I will come back
for some closing remarks unless you have
a need like that one moment Richard I'll
be brief it's just what a pleasure to
have the honor to be recognized with
this year's recipients in this Center
and those that have one in the past
particularly excited to see what happens
as we bring more data to the questions
that were all focusing on so thank you
so much no please IRA this is the best
part of the show it really is just like
this is great so congratulate you and
thank you for coming this wrong way
Miriam thank you very much for the world
I'm very honored to be here as Marcel
said I was frustrated I think at some
point in corporate governance you have
to say this is not good enough and you
have to take a step further but one
thing I want to say is the importance of
collaboration among institutional
investors even though each one of us may
be big compared to other investors if
you don't collaborate together we can't
really push for good progress and I
think that's what we achieved in Japan
so I'd like to say that this is
something that we should keep doing not
see each other as competitors by
somebody but as collaborative bodies to
push for good governance and for good
economies globally including Japan so
thank you very much and last but
certainly not least nermeen and just I'd
like to thank the advisory board for
selecting me and admin among others for
the 2015 rising star award it's really
our pleasure to receive such a
prestigious a word from columbia
universe thank you so much
so I'm sure you'll all join me one more
time in congratulating this year's
recipient and to the many nominees that
again we're outstanding individuals
congratulations to all of you we have a
lunch break now there's lunch in the
back of the room invite you to help
yourselves to relax get some fresh air
see the campus if you'd like at
one-thirty we have the Comptroller of
the city New York Scott stringer and
please be sure to be back for that
because that's a conversation you won't
want to miss
you